the complex welcoming external to
our ministerial ds discussion has
been very productive and moses adopted a
final document noun that addresses
the different will be the seat of cooperation the dice
elections florida spread our future
cooperation as wise as a large
class as to the
immediate tenemos withering  that complete
negotiation if in progress look
of association sto is happy with
this game is possible with mexico
marco source and meet in silk past
final i tenemos that to profess this
historic opportunity im and soul
rapid progress lo degree with chile
we will follow compromise  dos with
the implementation of the peace process
in colombia the implementation
of the association agreement and central
america our political agreement ide
cooperacion with cuba has now male nape
the world needs a nation sony da
sport.es expressed that he then fully
amos lo  effort of the forms of the
general secretary of the demo
ric  rdavo lined up your forces and
peace promotion initiative
followed it and to do it i sustainable
cooperation for arroyo gas
and trade impulse free taste
as generation of greater in
opportunity version
of influent equally  orient mass
media for dating and mitigation
also climate change but the
promotion of gender
the session as rosia where is
respect an important exchange
while the participating country and
above all the years of the condition the
rector continue finding point ago there
went that  commodore region discounted these
male values ​​in common we could
have a hugely positive impact
on the global agenda